WILL HAVE GREATER SUPPORT ON
CAPITOL HILL.
>> Bill: MARA, THANK YOU.
BYRON, THANKS.
STEPHEN HAYES, GOOD TO SEE A
PRETTY FOX NEWS ALERT RIGHT NOW.
BREAKING NEWS, TALLAHASSEE NOW,
THE FLORIDA STATE HOUSE HAS JUST
PASSED GUN LEGISLATION SPURRED
BY THE DEADLY SHOOTING THREE
WEEKS AGO.
INCLUDES NEW RESTRICTIONS ON
RIFLE SALES AND A PROGRAM TO ARM
SOME TEACHERS IN FLORIDA.
THE BILL ALSO PROVIDES NEW
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS FOR
SCHOOLS AND A PROVISION TO KEEP
GUNS AWAY FROM PEOPLE WHO SHOW
SIGNS OF MENTAL ILLNESS OR
VIOLENT BEHAVIOR.
THAT BILL NOW GOES TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK.
IT IS NOT CLEAR WHETHER OR NOT
GOVERNOR RICK SCOTT WILL SIGN
IT.